the Fifty Shades series is back on the
big screen with stars Dakota Johnson and
Jamie Dornan continuing Yael James's
story of Anna Steele and Christian Grey
so to mark the return the multi-million
dollar film franchise I put together
some crazy intriguing facts about the
Fifty Shades movie sequels after the
start film some audiences complained
that there wasn't enough shades of dawn
anon shown in fact even the 90 year old
co-editor of the Shades of Grey movie
and Coates thought the film could have
been raunchy to Kota Johnson also jokes
that she was going to start a campaign
to get Jamie Dornan fully naked in the
sequels and Dorland himself said that
you think Hollywood's double standards
on male and female nudity are unfair but
while Dornan has also said he's not
bothered about being nude on camera
she's remained pretty reticent about
what exactly is on show in shades darker
and Shades freed saying just a couple of
weeks after filming that he couldn't
remember despite that and the rumors
that he was offered over 1 million
dollars to reveal all in the sequels the
dawn and Diaz Dakota jokingly called it
remained firmly tucked away in a
flesh-colored bag during filming just
like it was in shades of grey now that
Jamie Dornan is known all over the world
for bringing Christian Grey to life on
the silver screen there's not many
places you can go without being
recognized by fans of Fifty Shades in
fact the funniest fan interaction he
remembered took place in an elevator and
no it was absolutely nothing like that
scene in fifty shades darker what
actually happened was that Dornan was in
an elevator when a very drunk woman
suddenly realized who he was and started
telling him that it was thanks to Al
James's erotic novels that she got
pregnant as after reading them she and
her husband began having a lot more sex
shooting the two sequels involved 160
sets and locations and 103 days of
filming in three countries and eight
cities in fact one of those locations
proved especially familiar for Jamie
Dornan who by a quirk of fate ended up
staying in not only the same hotels but
also the exact same room he'd stayed in
when he acted in his very first movie
mary antoinette over 10 years previously
and as if that wasn't enough of a deja
vu experience for Dawn and for the Fifty
Shades sequels he also filmed at the
Opera House by the hotel the very place
where he shot his first
I've seen as an actor and on top of that
the cinematographer on 50 shades darker
and Fifty Shades freed is John Schwarz
Minh who's the cousin of Mary Antoinette
writer and director Sofia Coppola and
the brother of Jason Schwartzman who
starred in Mary Antoinette along with
Jamie the biggest most demanding
sequence for the movies crew was the
masquerade ball at the gray family
mansion that featured in 50 shades
darker when she was writing the book
Elle Jane was faced the scene on her own
experience throwing to masquerade balls
but the filmmakers went for a different
look to the very restrained pastel
affair the James so she imagined when
writing however they did tip their hat
to the novel when it came to things like
the menu wine and auction items
production designer Nelson Coates was
inspired by the lavish looks of Venice
in its mask filled carnival and even
recreated an old Venetian cathedral
floor at the Vancouver Convention Centre
where they filmed the ball amid all the
extravagance of the masquerade scene
costume designer shaken lips wanted to
keep anna's look minimal making her
stand out as what she calls a beautiful
siren of simplicity so Anna's gown
channels old Hollywood especially 1930s
musicals I was created by LA based
fashion designer Monique Julie a few
clientele include Reese Witherspoon and
Scarlett Johansson and every single
feather indicate that Ana words as she
enters the ball was sewn on by hand
threatening the scenes more than two
hundred extras proved trickier than the
filmmakers first thought initially they
turned to the costume houses to rally in
Rome and malabar in Toronto to hire
period outfits but then the scene began
looking like an 18th century play so
they sent the outfits back and instead
went for a mix of costume pieces along
with formal party were including 1980s
couture in addition to that they also
brought hundreds of marks from classic
Marc makers embedded the Fifty Shades
sequels give even more insight into
Christian billionaire lifestyle for
example several new rooms were added to
his penthouse that weren't seen in the
previous films including a library in
billiard room that's home to a very
special Brunswick Centennial Art Deco
pool tables which is a limited edition
collector's item from just after the
Second World War the room also houses an
especially distinctive $17,000 chess set
by designer Kelly worth ler the seat to
the hand sculpted marble
and Golden Gun metal plated bronze
pieces in the shape of human body parts
including hands legs lips and torsos
forget the clean shaven Christians and
fifty shades of grey a new movie in the
series hasn't just gone darker it's also
gone stub Leah after complaints that
Jamie Dornan wasn't sporting his usual
bearded look in the first film the
filmmakers decided as stubble with the
way forward for Christian Grey's faith
in the sequels which is not only please
fans who love their leading man with
added facial furs but also dawn and
himself who absolutely hates shaving in
fact the Northern Irish accent even said
that he hates his face when it's
beardless because it makes him look too
young and since dawn and feels more at
ease with himself when he's unshaven he
always tries to say that way in each new
role he takes on the Fifty Shades
franchise may have played a big part in
Dakota Johnson and Jamie Dornan flies
catapulting into worldwide fame but
their nearest and dearest have yet to
see them on screen as Anna and Christian
and probably never will
yes although Dakota's parents working
girl star Melanie Griffith and Miami
Vice da Don Johnson are both veteran
actors themselves the source of watching
their daughter in the Fifty Shades films
is just too uncomfortable
indeed Dakota had a bit of an argument
about the subject with Melanie on the
red carpet at the 2015 Oscars but didn't
succeed in changing her mind but Melanie
does know what she's talking about when
she said it would be just too awkward to
watch the movies and she actually read
all the Fifty Shades books well before
her daughter auditioned for the role
however Melanie's decision to skip the
movies me shall miss out on a little
surprise tribute to her in fifty shades
darker so dakota hopes you'll at least
see a clip of that one particular moment
as for jamie dornan he said himself that
christian grey is not the sort of guy
he'd hang out with and at the step that
graders in the Fifty Shades movies
doesn't float his or his wife's boat and
Mike whitey understands why his wife
actress composed at Amelia Warner
doesn't want to watch the movies and
after all the birth of the couple's
daughters the first child
three days before filming kicked off on
shades of grey and the second two weeks
before the sequel started shooting is
more than enough for Amelia to remember
her husband's stint as Christine gray so
guys what do you think about the Fifty
Shades movies and how do you think they
compare to the books if you enjoyed this
video do
and I can hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to check out my other
videos and you can tap or click here to
do just that thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers